and met some friends and they were
selling drugs so it was like the thing
to do
sunday night at 8 p.m eastern on
c-span's q a
labor secretary alexander acosta held a
news conference wednesday to explain his
prior role as u.s attorney for the
southern district of florida in 2008
that led to a non-prosecution agreement
for financier jeffrey epstein who was
accused of sexual abuse at the time and
is now facing a new set of charges for
sex trafficking
this news conference from labor
department headquarters is just under an
hour
good afternoon
let me start by reiterating
that i'm pleased that the new york
prosecution is going forward
they brought these charges based on new
evidence against jeffrey epstein who is
now a registered sex offender
and this is a very very good thing
his acts are despicable
and new york prosecution offers an
important opportunity to more fully
bring epstein to justice
in 2008
a major newspaper described the epstein
prosecution like this
a florida grand jury
that is a grand jury convened by the
district attorney of palm beach county
had charged epstein with the lesser
offense
at that time the epstein legal team was
elated
he would have avoided prison altogether
but then the united states attorney's
office in miami became involved
epstein got an ultimatum
plead guilty to a charge that would
require jail time and registration
or
face federal charges
and that was the week
more than 10 years ago that epstein went
to jail
times have changed and coverage of this
case has certainly changed since that
article
facts are important and facts are being
overlooked
this matter started as a state matter
it was prosecuted initially by the state
of florida and not
by the u.s attorney's office
in 2006 a grand jury convened by the
state attorney the district attorney of
palm beach county reviewed the evidence
and recommended a single charge
and that charge would have resulted in
no jail time at all
no registration as a sexual offender and
no restitution to the victim
further
the state attorney's office allowed
epstein to self-surrender
and arraigned him the following morning
simply put
the palm beach state attorney's office
was ready to let epstein walk free
no jail time nothing
prosecutors in my former office found
this to be completely unacceptable
and they became involved our office
became involved
our prosecutors
as this 2008 article recounts presented
the ultimatum
plead guilty to more serious charges
charges that require jail time
registration and restitution
or we'd roll the dice
and bring a federal indictment
without the work of our prosecutors
epstein would have gotten away
with just that state charge
now many today question the terms of
that ultimatum
what's called the non-prosecution
agreement
good prosecutor will tell you that these
cases are complex
especially when they involve children
and even more so in 2006.
i've shared with those in this room
today and will make available publicly
an affidavit filed by the career
prosecutor in a civil matter related to
the epstein case
she talks about the challenges faced
she talks about the victims being scared
and traumatized
refusing to testify
and how some victims actually exonerated
epstein
most had significant concerns about
their identities being revealed
the acts that they had faced were
horrible
and they didn't want
people to know about
them and she goes on to write
that quote
after the fact
people allege that epstein would have
been easily convicted
as the prosecutor who handled the
investigation
she says in this affidavit
these contentions overlook the facts
that existed at the time
her description of these facts
are corroborated by the fbi case agent
whose affidavit i've also shared today
thousands of prosecutors around the
nation
this week
are weighing
guilty pleas versus trials
these cases have i said are heard
they require prosecutor to ask
whether a plea that guarantees jail time
and guarantees registration
to ask whether that plea
versus going to trial how do you weigh
those two
if going to trial is viewed as the role
of a dice
the goal here was straightforward
put epstein behind bars
ensured he registered as a sexual
offender provide victims with the means
to seek restitution and protect the
public by putting them on notice that a
sexual predator was in their midst
this case
people have said was unusual
and it was it was complicated by the
fact
that this matter started as a state
investigation
a state grand jury brought
that single
completely
unacceptable charge
a state
official
allowed epstein to self-surrender
and so it is unusual because it's
unusual for a federal prosecutor to
intervene in a state matter
such as this we've seen cases recently
different set of facts
different i don't want anyone to say i'm
comparing these cases but we've seen
other cases
where state prosecutors let folks
go with no sentence and people shake
their heads
in this case
the federal office intervened before the
plea was taken and said stop
because if that plea is taken at the
state level
you're going to face serious federal
issues
today we know a lot more about how
victims trauma impacts their testimony
and this too is important
our juries are more accepting of
contradictory statements
understanding that trauma-impacted
memories work differently
and today our judges
do not allow victim shaming by defense
attorneys
i have viewed the victim interviews
they're hard to watch
because i know that my former colleagues
the men and women of my office
wanted to help them
i wanted to help them
that is why
we intervened
and that's what the prosecutors of my
office did
they insist that he go to jail
and put the world on notice that he was
and is a sexual predator
epstein's actions absolutely deserve a
stiffer sentence
for years there have been rumors of
investigations in other jurisdictions
and he should be prosecuted in any state
in which he committed a crime
if there are other states in which he
committed crimes if there are other
states that can bring state charges
they should consider those as well
and so i absolutely welcome this new
york prosecution it is the absolutely
right thing to do
and i'm happy to take questions
eric
how would you describe your relationship
with the president
the news that the cycle here with
epstein is changing that
um my relationship with the president's
outstanding
he has i think very publicly
made clear that that
i've got his support he spoke yesterday
in the oval office he and i have spoken
let me add i keep reading about articles
about my relationship with me and mr
mulvaney
and he called me this morning to say if
asked that our relationship is excellent
too and that any articles to the
contrary are in his words bs
um
and uh and so
it's
i'm here i'm defending this case that's
my job
tom yamas abc news
secretary a lot of people are watching
this news conference including several
young women who say they were teenagers
when jeffrey epstein sexually assaulted
them they say they went to you looking
for help and they didn't hear back from
you until it was too late
do you owe them an apology
so you're raising the issue of victim
notification
and um
in the documents that i've circulated
i've addressed the issue of victim
notification as well
the career prosecutor in this case
had a difficult decision to make and she
didn't make it alone she made it in
consultation with the fbi and she made
it in consultation with the office
the agreement that had been negotiated
had an unusual provision
even though this was a state case
the victims would have the opportunity
to receive restitution
epstein would be required to pay for
them to hire a lawyer
to bring a case against him
a case in which he would have to plead
no contest
and provide them with restitution
and the concern and these are the words
of the career prosecutor
that quote she did not want to share
with the victims
that the office was attempting to secure
for them the ability to obtain monetary
compensation because she is aware that
if she disclosed that and the
negotiations fell through
epstein's council would
use this to question the victim's
credibility and her concerns were not
hypothetical
one of epstein's attorneys had already
asked one of the victims quote
now tell me about when the federal
prosecutors told you about getting money
and so when the agreement was signed
shortly after the agreement was signed
epstein's councils indicated that
epstein may not comply with the
agreement
and the agreement was appealed at
various levels within the justice
department
and she details in this affidavit
an affidavit that's also corroborated by
the fbi case agent
how she and he
and the office was concerned that
epstein might not comply
and we would have to go to trial
and we had to weigh
the issue of how much to disclose
against the issue if we have to go to
trial
we want to win we want to put epstein
away
and talking about this
would allow
him to make the argument at trial
that their testimony was compromised
and so when she was finally when it was
finally clear
that epstein would comply with the
agreement she talks about how she made
efforts to notify the victims
how that was a friday afternoon at 4 15
and that she learned
that the state had scheduled the plea
for 8 30 the following monday
and she talks about how over the weekend
she made every effort to notify the
victims at that
you mr time uh earlier you described the
approach uh
negotiating this deal as an ultimatum to
mr mrexcel
and
i wanted to uh draw your attention to uh
standards for prosecutors uh it's
getting three dash four point three
which says a prosecutor should see
profound criminal charges only if the
prosecuting these we believe in these
will be sufficient to support conviction
the unoriginal doubt and the decision to
charge is in the interest of justice
did you believe certain that
the evidence against epstein
would have been sufficient to secure
convictions beyond the reasonable doubt
for the federal offenses against in the
non-prosecution agreement and
if so
why was it not in the interest of
justice to charge him with these crimes
so again i would refer you to the
documents i've
provided there is
a big gulf between sufficient evidence
to go to trial
and sufficient evidence to be confident
in the outcome of that trial
and so so if i could and i'll i'll give
you a follow-up in a minute but if i
could and so
when this case and i provided a letter
that outlined some of the timeline of
this
in july of 2007
the career staff from my office met and
they said these are the four points that
you will have to do
in state court
and if not we will proceed federally
they
were very serious that they would
proceed federally that does not mean
that they were confident in the final
outcome and one of the tough questions
in these cases
what is the value of a secured guilty
plea
with registration versus rolling the
dice
and i know that in 2019 looking back on
2008 things may look different
but this was the judgment
of prosecutors with dozens of years of
experience if you look through that
letter you'll see this was not a single
person making those decisions we wanted
to follow up so first
uh you describe
what would happen if uh after the
objective builds uh you would roll the
dice
with charges and i understand that
you're
uh saying now that uh it's it's never
it's never a slam dunk
but
it's it seems that it seems like you're
you're making
this out to be a case in which you held
the possibility of a federal indictment
over the head of mr epstein to get him
to plead to a lesser crime and that in
and of itself
is against the aba um i i do not think
that the office
violated the aba standards
by negotiating strongly and forcefully
so standing here today are you basically
saying that you feel that you did
everything you could you got the best
deal you could get and you have no
regrets
we believe that we proceeded
appropriately that based on the evidence
and not just my opinion but i've shared
the affidavit based on the evidence
there was value to
getting a guilty plea and having him
registered
look no regrets is a very hard question
at my confirmation hearing i was asked a
similar question one of the
one of the issues that i raised is we
expect a lot more transparency today
as you watch these victim
interviews
it's very obvious that the victims
feel that this was not a sufficient
outcome these victims were traumatized
we can't begin to understand
what they went through and they look at
this and they say but why
and so you always look back and you say
what if
what i can say is at the time
and i've provided a timeline of provided
information about the individuals
involved this was
the view
of the office
there is a value to a sure guilty plea
because letting him walk letting what
the state attorney was ready to do
go forward
would have been absolutely
awful
ben
yes ben penn from bloomberg law um you
know in light of the uh attention this
week on on your handling of uh back in
2008 victims of sex trafficking i wanted
to ask about your role today as a
secretary of labor you have oversight
through the wage and hour division of
certifying visas for victims of human
trafficking including sex trafficking
and just last week your wage and hour
division issued a new policy
that would essentially allow the agency
it's being criticized by a lot of people
i talked to for allowing the agency to
completely remove itself or to virtually
remove itself from
continuing to certify these visas by
referring them to other agencies how can
you defend what was the purpose of that
so so that that is if you read the
policy that is not what it does our wage
and hour administrator after she was
confirmed came in and she reviewed the
policies
and she put in place a requirement
that a criminal prosecutor be consulted
any time one of these
issues is brought to the division's
attention and that seems very reasonable
don't we want criminal prosecutors to be
consulted whenever someone says that
they're a victim of trafficking
and
that prosecutor will be consulted and
even if that prosecutor says this is not
a case that we are going forward with
the division will still consider whether
to issue that visa on the facts so that
is a mischaracterization of her decision
and her policy
yes could you go into a bit more detail
about where and how
uh you exactly negotiated this deal did
you meet with epstein's attorney alone
at a marriott hotel so you know i've
read this and one of the things i find
interesting is how
how facts
become facts because they're in a
newspaper as opposed to the record
i pulled up i i found out the details of
that meeting because i scratched my own
head about it and i've provided you a
timeline in a letter of the negotiations
that make it very clear that this was
negotiated by career prosecutors
the i'm going to answer your question
the meeting that was alleged was a
breakfast meeting that took place after
the agreement was negotiated not before
the agreement was signed in september
after the agreement was negotiated one
of epstein's attorneys asked for a
meeting asked for a hearing i was giving
a speech i was staying at a hotel i
agreed to have a brief meeting i believe
at 7 am
rather than open the office i spoke with
that
attorney and then i referred that
attorney to the career prosecutors
nothing changed in that agreement they
continued to litigate the matter they
continued to peel the matter to
washington and nothing changed with one
one exception there was an addendum
that made clear that epstein had to pay
for any attorney that a victim
that represented a victim in the cases
against
epstein and so
yes i met with opposing counsel it was a
breakfast meeting because i was staying
at the hotel it was after
after not before and not part of the
negotiations but it was after the
agreement had been negotiated and that
could be confirmed simply by looking at
the date on the agreement and the date
on the meeting
so
number one the agreement had already
been locked in place so the agreement
wasn't going to change before that
agreement you know i was very careful to
not negotiate this our career attorneys
negotiated the agreement secondly i'd
point out we live in a city where people
have breakfast meetings all the time you
don't open an office at seven o'clock in
the morning just to have a meeting you
have it over breakfast
it's not standard for a non-prosecution
agreement to include a scene let me let
me let me do this i i i had called in
i'll come back to you i'll come back to
you don't the young girl i i wanted to
give ian an opportunity i'll come back
to you in a minute
thank you sir um you've mentioned
several times that you
and the prosecutors in your office
weren't sure that you could secure a win
in this case but the very purpose of the
of the cvra
is to give the victims an opportunity
to weigh in and a federal judge ruled
that you broke federal law by not doing
so do you think that your thinking would
have been different had you followed the
law and
consulted the victims so um first let me
let me point out we followed department
policy
department policy at the time made very
clear
and this is in a written statement that
was subsequently issued by what is
called the office of legal counsel which
is the chief policy making the chief
legal arm of the department of justice
that these situations with
non-prosecution agreements
are not covered by the cbra at the time
because the cbra according to department
policy does not attach
until a case is actually brought now i
understand that the judge had a
different view and i understand that the
judge's view was that department policy
did not comply with the law
and that's the way our system works our
system works in that a judge can say
what the department policy is is not
consistent with the law now let me also
point out since then a few years ago
congress amended the cvra and congress
amended it explicitly
to say that
non-prosecution agreements would be in
fact covered and that is a good thing i
as i said at my confirmation hearing
you know we expect a lot more
transparency
if we had had more transparency perhaps
this case would have gone differently
i've laid out the reasons
why there were concerns about
providing all the details to the victims
before
epstein pled
but
the department of justice has been very
clear throughout multiple presidential
administrations throughout multiple
attorneys general
that the department's position is that
there was no violation of the law
would you make that
your name and who you're with i'm
caitlin collins for cnn
would you make this same agreement today
so these questions are always very
difficult
because
we now have
12 years
of knowledge in hindsight and we live in
a very different world
today's world treats victims very very
differently
today's world does not allow some of the
victim shaming that could have taken
place at trial
12 years ago today's world
understands that when interviewing
victims when eliciting testimony that
testimony can be sometimes contradictory
that memories
are difficult
and so i don't think we can say
you know take a case that is this old
and fully know how it would play out
today
i understand what the victims say and
i'm not here
to try to say that i can stand in their
shoes
or that i can address
their concerns
i'm here to say
we did what we did because we wanted to
see epstein go to jail he needed to go
to
jail
he needed he needed
he needed to go to jail
and that was that was the focus john fun
john
john
mr secretary can i ask you a question
about the office yes hi peter alexander
from nbc to be clear dozens of girls
were allegedly molested why didn't you
just keep investigating and that'll
follow
so
the
victims of which we were aware
were part of this and under the
agreement in the southern district of
florida the investigation ceased and
they had the opportunity to proceed
civilly that does not mean that the
investigation had to cease nationwide
and as we see today as we saw in new
york
investigations could certainly
and obviously have proceeded in other
districts
how can you be trusted to enforce human
trafficking laws as secretary of labor
given your history with this case
so
i have been i started one of the first
human trafficking task forces at the
department of justice
i have been aggressive prosecuting human
trafficking we stood
we stepped in in this case
and we stopped a bad state plea
and so i understand
from today's perspective that people
scratch their heads and they say why
here's the question to ask how many
other times have you seen a u.s
attorney's office
intervene
in a state matter
and say
stop the state plea because it is
insufficient
yes
with reuters i want to ask you a
question about the office of
professional responsibility um earlier
this year it was disclosed that they're
going to they're doing a review into how
you and other prosecutors in your office
handle this matter what is the status of
that what exactly are they looking at
will you submit to an interview even
though you're no longer with the justice
department and if they find any
misconduct will you resign
um
first i don't know what the status of
that is
i would refer that to the office of
professional responsibility i don't
speak for them
i will clearly submit for an interview
even though i don't have to
i think what they do is important the
office of professional responsibility
will have access to the full record they
will have access to all the facts they
will have access to the fbi reports
they'll have access to the victim
interviews they can look at this matter
in its totality
um and and so i think it is important
that they proceed
i will gladly be part of it and and i
think what they will find is that the
office acted appropriately
pbs newshour as labor secretary you've
tried repeatedly to cut a program that
deals with with human trafficking in the
labor department by up to 80
going before congress advocating for
that why should people trust you to
focus on human trafficking and protect
victims if you've done that and i'd like
a follow-up question
so you're referring to grants that go to
foreign countries
for foreign country
labor-related work as part of the budget
every year
those grants have been removed as have
other grants for foreign countries and
let me just add as part of the budget
every year those grants are put right
back in by congress
this is what happens in washington and i
fully suspect that those grants will
remain in this year your follow-up
my follow-up question is
sources have told me that the president
encouraged you to hold this press
conference can you speak a little bit
about what the president told you ahead
of this press conference and whether
you're you're here to give a message to
the president are you fighting for your
job or are you trying to send a message
to victims and if so what is the message
to victims who say they don't trust you
anymore so first i'm not about to talk
about conversations with the president
and i'm not here to send any signal to
the president i think it's important a
lot of questions were raised and i this
has reached the point that i think it's
important to have the public hearing i
think it's important that these
questions be asked and answered
and as to a message to the victims
the message is you need to come forward
i heard this morning that another victim
came forward
and made horrendous horrendous
allegations
allegations that should never happen to
any
woman much less a young girl
and
as victims come forward these cases can
be brought and they can be brought by
the federal government they can be
brought by state attorneys
and they will be brought we have seen in
the last few years cases brought against
individuals that got away with things
for well over a decade
and you know it's it's important to
realize that people were getting away
with these people were not going to jail
at all
and were aware of those high profile
cases and we've seen as victims come
forward
how the justice system deals with them
and so the message to victims is come
forward sir mr secretary
let me take a few more hi mr secretary
richard madden ctv you just said victims
need to come sorry richard madden with
ctv television you just said a moment
ago the victim should come forward but
you still haven't
offered an apology to them why is that
so
the victims should come forward because
the justice system needs to hear from
them
and what the victims went through is
horrific what the victims continue to go
through is horrific
i've seen these videos
i've seen the interviews
i'm sorry i've seen the interviews on on
television of these victims
and and their stories and and so
it's hard
but i also think it's important that we
understand that the men and women of my
office
going back to 2006 and 2007 and 2008
have spent their career prosecuting
these types of cases
and in their heart
in our heart we were trying to do the
right thing for these victims
and so this is horrific this is awful
each one of these cases is just
devastating and saddening
but i also think it's important to
realize that the prosecutors were trying
to do the right thing sir
yeah jeff earl from daily mail how are
you um are you aware of alleged
obstruction of justice by mr epstein uh
it seemed to have been mentioned in a
in a note in a bail memo by new york
prosecutors and did he take efforts to
to intimidate prosecutors and if he did
or harass witnesses pamper witnesses if
he did that why would he get what's been
viewed what's been called a sweetheart i
i can't i can't comment on the new york
case that that that would not be
appropriate
in florida i'm talking about in florida
did you structure sir there is a pending
your case in new york i can't comment
sir
i'm curious who at maine justice neil
mckay one american news who at maine
justice reviewed this case or your
decision and did you have any
interaction with robert mueller at the
time
um so i i shared a letter
that i wrote to one of epstein's defense
attorneys and i shared that letter in
part because it shows much of the
timeline it shows how initially
the
the meetings that took place
were between the uh in july
between the first assistant the criminal
chief the palm beach the palm beach
office chief and the line attorney and
two fbi agents with epstein's attorneys
you'll notice at the initial meeting as
outlined in this letter who are all
career attorneys how they presented the
terms
how epstein's attorneys were
dissatisfied and asked for a meeting
with me how i subsequently went with
their attorneys along with all the
career officials how at that meeting we
then invited the chief
of the child exploitation obscenity
section from the department of justice
to travel down
because one of them
you know one of the things we wanted to
make sure of was that we had going back
to the earlier question about the aba
rule that we had sufficient evidence to
proceed ethically
um and then it details a little bit on
how
epstein's councils appealed the
decisions to washington i'd refer you to
the record you know one of the really
disturbing things about this case
is there's a record here
the documents that i shared today we've
shared previously with media
yet i've seen no reference
to any of these documents and the
perspective
of some of these prosecutors
there's a record all these documents are
publicly available
and could have been pulled up by anyone
in this room
and so and and so
you know
there there is a record
that will you know i wasn't at maine
justice i do not have a full list of the
individuals that that reviewed this
matter and main justice i can tell you
um the individual's reference in this
letter um and and i would refer you to
the record because i this was 12 years
ago i do not have a full list of the
individuals that review this at maine
justice
well as the record makes clear
individuals from maine justice were
involved
fairly early on and were certainly aware
of it and and i think if you look at the
record it will become clear that our
decisions were appealed again and again
to two main justices sir thank you um
shiver from the financial times
um so the deal that you negotiated uh
resulted in two things
one is that the case ended with mr
epstein pleading to state prostitution
charges and another thing that it did
was that it immunized his
co-conspirators so two questions did you
consider his victims in that case to be
prostitutes and why did you immunize his
co-conspirators
so the answer to were the victims
prostitutes no
victims they were victims end of story
they were victims
um the second part of that is in
the purpose in this case was to bring
epstein
to
jail to put him behind bars
and so there were other individuals that
may have been involved that um
in any type of conspiracy they're
individuals around someone
the focus really is on the top player
and that's where our focus appropriately
was
let me um let me also say something
because a lot has been said about this
13 month
when we proceeded
the expectation was that it would be an
18-month sentence and the expectation
was that it would be served in jail
and so this work release was complete bs
and i've been on record as far back as
2011 saying that it was not what was
bargained for and it was not what we
expected but this was a state court plea
and because it was a state court plea
the terms of confinement were under the
jurisdiction of the state of florida
and so the outrage over that 13 month
you know getting to to leave jail is
entirely appropriate
when we entered into this
we i at least fully thought that he
would be spending the time in jail
that's what we mean by someone going to
jail
mr secretary sir if i can get um
network if i can get a brief statement
in spanish i would really appreciate it
um i'll tell you what if you answer the
you want if you ask me a question in
spanish i will answer in spanish is that
fair
i was trying to get a brief statement i
mean so that i
will go over with what everyone already
says
is
[Music]
did you ask the question already i do
okay
let me let me go to someone
you said earlier that your message to
victims was to come forward what's your
message specifically to those who did
come forward and felt let down by you um
they came look
victims came forward and there were
several victims you know i believe that
in one of the filings the department of
justice
talked to several of the victims
and some of the victims just didn't want
any any public notoriety
other victims have provided interviews
and said they felt
let down that they were let down
these are really hard cases
the prosecutors in my office and i were
focused on putting him in jail
i provided the information
from the career attorney as to why there
were concerns if we went to trial
and it became clear that they were going
to receive money
if he was convicted how that would
impeach their credibility and and today
that would proceed very differently
because victim shaming is is just not
accepted
but the circumstances of trials and what
juries
would consider
12 years ago was different and so these
were the judgments that were made
i understand that that individuals will
look at these judgments and say well
maybe a different judgment should have
been made
you know you can always look at a play
after the fact and say should it have
been the safe play or should you have
gone for the big score
and ask which is the right outcome
but i provided these documents so that
you could hear from the prosecutors
themselves how these doc how this was
being weighed
sir
uh jesse seidman vice news did the miami
howard reach out to you last november
and if so why don't you set the record
straight on the breakfast meeting then
um so media has reached out to me over
the years about this i i think it's very
important the department of justice
is the entity that is litigating all
these matters
and quite honestly until
until recently i haven't commented on
this since 2011 because i think it's
important for the united states to
litigate cases through the department of
justice
and if former u.s attorneys responded to
media inquiries about pending cases
and this is a pending case there was a
live and there still is a live civil
matter the former u.s attorneys
responded to media inquiries all the
time we'd have havoc in our justice
system you can't have a department of
justice as a litigating entity
with u.s attorneys giving press
statements now your follow-up question
may be why am i talking today
and the answer is this has clearly
reached a level
where i thought it was important to have
this kind of press conference to take
questions
um and and to to provide these facts and
these perspectives
and i understand that individuals may
say this was not enough
but this is the way it was viewed not
only by me
but by many back in 2008
yes doug christian from talk media news
one thing yes
um you said that the victims were not
prostitutes but the
agreement was
he was jailed for prostitution charges
not for child
for sex trafficking
can you just uh
the agreement the agreement was this was
a state here's here's why this is hard
this was a state case
he was
arraigned he
a state grand jury returned a
prostitution charge against him a
solicitation charge if i recall that was
a state grand jury he was allowed to
self-surrender by the state attorney's
office
as a result of that single charge that
would have resulted in no jail time
and ultimately what the agreement did
was
say you have to go back and you have to
plead to a more serious state charge
that requires jail time that requires
registration and under this agreement
you'll have a mechanism for restitution
but the agreement itself you know
ultimately the state of florida and the
state attorney's office in florida is a
separate sovereign the u.s attorney does
not determine how those offices
run themselves or what charges they
bring
i do not consider the victims
prostitutes i think that is insulting to
them
these were victims they were not just
women victims they were children victims
secretary mr secretary um
i'm deborah saunders with the las vegas
review journal
um
since mr epstein left jail he's been a
public figure
he's
been a man about town he hasn't seemed
particularly contrite about what he did
what have you thought when you've seen
him
you know what i've thought is i keep
reading newspaper articles about pending
investigations here or there you know if
uh if someone does a google search
they'll see that there were rumors of
investigations going on for the last 10
years
and
new york finally stood up and stood up
and they took one of those
investigations and they brought charges
and in all kinder i wish it would have
happened um i'm glad to see that it's
happening now um
he's a you know he's a bad man and and
he needs to be put away and um
you know based on additional allegations
that i saw this morning um there are
multiple jurisdictions whether federal
or state that that he's going to have to
answer to a few a few more few more
questions yes alex dougherty with miami
herald i wanted to ask him follow up
with your answer the earlier question
about the potential co-conspirators were
you confident at the time that any
potential additional co-conspirators
didn't commit
sexual abuses against underage girls
like epstein did even if it may not have
been the same scale because some of
those victims have accused others of
doing similar acts to them so um
let me see how i can address your
question without running a foul of
department of justice guidelines
if
my office had been aware of individuals
who committed
acts
such as as sexual abuse
you know my office it would not have
been my position that those individuals
should have been part of of that kind of
of immunity it's not even immunity
should not have been part of that
paragraph and so so i know that there
are a lot of rumors about who those
individuals may or may not be
um i think those rumors
are misconstruing the acts of the office
with respect to that particular
paragraph
one more question
richard lardner from the associated
press mr terry were you ever made aware
at any point in your handling of this
case if mr epstein was an intelligence
asset of some sort
um so
so so there has there has been reporting
to that effect
and and let me say um there's been
reporting to a lot of effects in in this
case uh not just now but over the years
and and again i would
you know i would hesitate to take
this reporting as fact
this was a case that was brought by our
office it was brought based on the facts
and and i look at that reporting and
others i can't address it directly
because of our
uh our guidelines um but i can tell you
that that a lot of reporting is just
going down rabbit holes a few a few more
questions a few more questions have you
asked a question yet i have but i guess
okay
how about that in front of you yes
sorry i'm i'm trying to to do a one
question per person
okay can i go ahead yeah hi uh katie
rogers with the new york times i'm just
wondering what makes you so confident
that the president is going to continue
to have you serve there have been
several advisors of his who he stands he
stands up for initially but you're about
at the level where he has backed away
before so what makes you so confident so
um
i i am here to talk about this case i'm
doing my job if at some point the
president decides that i am not the best
person to do this job i respect that
that is his choice i serve at the
pleasure of the president um
i thought yesterday he was kind and he
showed great support um
but
we have to remember we are here
because we are part of an administration
that is creating jobs that is creating
growth that is really transforming our
economy and focusing it on
you know the the forgotten man and woman
and if at some point he says look you
know you're not the right person for
this right now or for you know you're
standing in the way i respect that
secretary cosby yes
thanks um do you really have nothing
else to say to these victims beyond you
should come forward that places a lot of
burden on children um what else do you
have to say you've avoided addressing
these these people directly why is that
so so
to be clear that is not all i said
you know i think
if i recall and i obviously don't have a
transcript here but you know what i've
said previously is
i have seen these interviews and i can't
i generally can't begin to fathom what
these victims have been through
i don't think that anyone that has not
been in this situation can begin to
fathom the closest i can come is to
think what would i feel like if one of
my girls
was going through this and and i would
be
you know i'm not sure i can say the way
i would feel on television um
but but even that is different than what
the victims themselves went through and
so
the point i'm trying to make is
everything that the victims have gone
through in these cases is horrific
and their response is entirely justified
at the same time
i think it's important to stand up for
the prosecutors of my former office
and make clear that what they were
trying to do was help these victims
they should not be
portrayed as individuals that just
didn't care because they have spent a
lifetime
of bringing cases
like this they are individuals who
really really do care
that's not another college is that right
anymore
yeah
yes um
hi i'm nikki schwab new york post how
much of this do you think was um epstein
getting special treatment because of his
enormous enormous wealth and also
political connections
so
you know i've heard a lot about that and
um
if you go through the record you will
see that in july he was presented with
certain terms
and and i laid this out in a letter an
open letter that i wrote to address some
of these questions in 2011
and he was presented with terms
and the office throughout this entire
negotiation and it took several months
from july to what december
through these five months of
negotiations stuck to those terms you go
to jail
you
register and you provide restitution
the original term was two years
the office ultimately agreed to 18
months
registry it had to be an effect it had
to be an offense
where there was registration because the
world needed to be on notice that he was
a sexual predator
and it had to be a situation where the
victims could seek restitution because
it wasn't just enough
for him to go to jail and let me also
say you know i
restitution is also not enough you can
never put victims
in the place they were before they were
victimized you can't unwind history but
restitution is important thank you very
much
you mentioned his legal team you
mentioned his legal team how powerful
his lawyers were that they put pressure
on you did they put pressure on dc did
someone at doj tell you or order you to
cut a deal with jeffrey epstein his his
attorneys um certainly
filed several appeals with maine justice
i will
again restate when the career attorneys
met with him
they presented certain terms and the
office stay true to those terms
throughout
those terms did not change the agreement
did not change
no level of appeal to maine justice
changed the terms of these
initial
points in those agreements
one last right right there yes ma'am hi
caitlyn fulmer i just had a question for
you and the proposed remedies from jane
doe one and two one of their requests is
to can they just meet with you i know
you're not apologizing today but would
you be willing to meet with them you
know that's a really that's a really
good question um
this is currently in litigation and so i
i don't want to um
i don't want to interfere with that
litigation but let me just say
i have monitored this litigation
without
you know i haven't monitored day to day
i have never pulled the full record but
i have watched it
and i have seen
what these victims have gone through and
and whenever this litigation is
concluded um i've always had an open
door policy and i've always welcomed the
opportunity to sit down and i think it'd
be really healthy for prosecutors to
sometimes circle back
and
and really hear about what happened
because we all have to learn you know
one of the one of the questions that
came up at my confirmation hearing was
what would you do differently and i
alluded to this and i said the world is
much more transparent we expect a lot
more from government we are a less
trusting society
we can wonder whether that's right or
wrong but we are a less trusting society
today
in part because
our culture expects transparency
and so
to sit down and hear from victims
how
this impacted them
i think would be healthy for prosecutors
generally i can't commit in this
particular case it's in litigation but i
think that would be healthy for
prosecutors generally thank you very
much
[Applause]
in 1979 a small network with an unusual